this came before police body cameras and
mobile phones the beating of Rodney King
by Los Angeles police officers filmed by
a neighbor with a camcorder it was the
first time America had been forced to
confront such savagery from their living
rooms the brutalizing of a black man by
those who swore to protect
King survived but there are painful
parallels to The Tyree Nichols footage
and few feel it as keenly as King's
Daughter
no one has to explain this to their
children
I hope one day we can look back and
realize just how ignorant we were and I
say we because we all are from here we
live here we should be working together
so that this never happens
um it seems like it's no change except
for hashtags and clear videos
the Rodney King video in subsequent
acquittal of four police officers
sparked violent protests in Los Angeles
and Beyond it's been 31 years since but
America continues to wrestle with its
police problem
in 2014 Michael Brown an unarmed black
teenager in Ferguson Missouri was shot
dead by a white police officer Brianna
Taylor a medical worker killed during a
botched raid on her apartment they are
the high-profile cases in a country
where death at the hands of law
enforcement is routine
please don't shoot me man this video of
George Floyd being murdered by white
police officer Derek chovin revived the
horror and prompted an explosive wave of
protest
public Focus sharpened on a system
infected by violence and police reform
laws were passed with haste body camera
footage is now more routinely made
public whether it exonerates the
officers or dams them as in the case of
Tyree Nichols offices in the United
States were certainly in urban areas are
all well trained the issues in these
offices they were well trained these
were not untrained officers the
questions if they don't file their
training what responsibility that that
do they have and this is the case where
the supervisors must in fact whole
options accountable when they see that
they've engaged in misconduct and that
has to occur in a uniform way
America is still demanding change but
the Swift charging of the office is
involved in the beating of Tyree Nichols
and transparency around the video has
perhaps encouraged peaceful protest and
convinced some that Justice is underway
Martha Kellner Sky News